foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar the
evolution of cervical cancer screening
from paps to precise personalized
programs
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by BD
to learn more please visit bd.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Anu Reba pragata director and Senior
advisor for Diagnostic strategy and
Services microbix biosystems
Incorporated
Dr R you may now begin your presentation
thank you Kaylee hello everyone it's a
pleasure to join you today and talk
about the evolution of cervical cancer
screening we're at an exciting time
right now where we can harness the
knowledge from decades and inform a more
enhanced personalized and precise
cervical cancer screening program my
presentation today will focus on the
cancer screening landscape in Canada but
I will also speak to the global
improvements in cancer screening and the
knowledge accumulated over the years so
let's get started
this is a brief uh disclaimer on on the
presentation this presentation is on
behalf of becton Dickinson and uh the
opinions that I am presenting here are
for informational purposes only and
um are derived from my my research and
studies
here's an overview of the objectives for
my presentation today so I'll walk you
through the evolution of cervical cancer
screening we've certainly come a long
way from from the time of Pap screens
and I will I'll highlight The Landmark
discoveries that have led us to this
point today
um then follow that with a focus on the
current state of the Canadian landscape
excuse me I see that my slides are not
moving
do you see my slides now
great thank you
um sorry about that so moving on we will
focus on the current state of the
Canadian landscape and follow that with
the critical challenges we face not only
in Canada but across the globe with
cervical cancer screening and what needs
to be done to achieve the goal of cancer
elimination and I'll I'll then end my
presentation with some solutions to
address the various issues and given the
complexity of cervical cancer screening
access to screening vaccination and the
changes as a result of vaccination I'll
try to put all the puzzle pieces
together to elucidate what can be done
to improve programs
and I hope the slides are advancing
um so let's start off with the evolution
of screening
um and as the the previous slide showed
it it often feels like rolling uh a big
ball up up a giant Hill much like
Sisyphus rolling up a giant boulder but
the challenge with HPV is not just
rolling up one HPV as you know it
belongs to a family of viruses and we
need to be aware of
um the risk of type replacement with the
family of other high-risk viruses that
that may be present
okay so the history of cervical cancer
screening really began in the early 20s
when George Papa Nicola began his
studies on vaginal smears and
um really that was a landmark in itself
the ability to visualize these cells and
pinpoint what are abnormal pre-cancerous
cells as a result of implementation of
the pap screening program the mortality
rates with cervical cancer began to
decline dramatically and you can see the
the stats that are circled there in blue
um from the 1930s to the 1980s there was
a dramatic decline in the mortality rate
associated with cervical cancer in the
U.S from 36 women in 100 000 to only
seven uh in a hundred thousand but still
cervical cancer persists
and the other landmark Discovery was the
identification by Dr Harold zerhausen
that cervical cancer is initiated by
infection with HPV a virus so really the
connection between a virus as an
ideological agent for a cancer was
groundbreaking in itself and helped
usher in a new way to to look at cancer
by looking at the virus the causative
agent for for this cancer and as a
result of that Discovery
um uh there was a lot of work in new
kinds of testing new diagnostic
modalities the development of HPV based
tests and as you can see there were
several iterations of tests that were
approved over the years the first
high-risk HPV test was approved
in the late 1990s and after that there's
been a whole slew of new diagnostic
tests that have come to the market with
different features and I will review
some of the the key Design Elements and
performance elements that determine
suitability for cervical cancer
screening programs
in parallel the field of cytology
continued to evolve as well and the
Bethesda system was created this this
helped with the classification of the
abnormal abnormal cells and improved the
triage and the follow-up of women based
on the type of cellular abnormalities
that were noticed microscopically
certainly the approval of the the first
HPV vaccine
um and against HPV 16 and 18-2 high-risk
oncogenic types and 6 and 11 which cause
genital warts was a great step forward
in preventing cervical cancer by
vaccinating young girls who have not yet
encountered the virus
and the field of vaccinology continued
to improve with introduction and
development of Gardasil 9 which now
covers many more high-risk types
including type 31 33 45 52 and 58 in a
nine valent vaccine
um so there are many different streams
of activity and evolution that have
converged together to bring us to where
we are today in 2022
um and consequently with these
improvements came the recommendation to
move to primary HPV screening uh instead
of Pap cytology-based screening and
we'll walk through why those changes
happened
and
so uh before we get to HPV screening as
I mentioned Pap screening itself has
evolved from a conventional pap smear to
liquid-based cytology the advancement
with liquid-based cytology or LBC is it
provided a high quality representative
sample with better exfoliation of cells
better preservation but better
visualization and as a result this
improved the sensitivity and specificity
of identifying abnormal pre-cancerous
cells
the limitations of the conventional pap
smear are well known now variable
specimen collection limited number of
cells that were transferred to the pap
smear slide and this of course led to
misdetection of abnormal cells and the
low sensitivity High false negative rate
in addition contaminants such as blood
and bacteria occluded the detection of
abnormal cells on the slide
so in comes liquid-based cytology which
is now considered the gold standard for
cervical specimen collection the brush
itself provides better exfoliation of
cervical epithelial cells better
preservation of those cells in the
medium in which it's collected this also
minimizes degradation and maintains cell
quality improved this certainly improves
the visualization microscopically but
also preserves the sample for molecular
testing by HPV based methodologies so
really promotes not only cytology but
new kinds of testing looking at HPV and
perhaps in the future for other
biomarkers associated with progression
of cervical cancer
and Beyond the collection of the sample
there's been advances in imaging and
digital screening which further reduce
human error and subjectivity of of how a
cervical cancer
slide is ranked
as I mentioned the Bethesda
classification for cervical squamous
cells also improved the interpretation
and reporting of cervical cancer and
pre-cancerous cells so a much more
precise way of identifying the types of
cells and abnormalities of observed
microscopically
um so now I will briefly describe the
the process of HPV infection and the
mechanism of cervical cancer development
and certainly this is well-known and
well characterized but it was a
groundbreaking discovery that a virus
was the trigger for cancer formation and
HPV is an unusual virus compared to some
of the other sexually transmitted
viruses like HIV
so HPV is also sexually transmitted it
gains entry into the cervical epithelium
through breaks and tears in the mucosa
and travels within the the different
layers of the cervical squamous
epithelium and here it establishes
itself in the basal keratinocytes where
it replicates and most of this
replication is episomally within the
cells it doesn't integrate yet and it
happily continues to to replicate let's
see this is slated lines
um so it infects the basal cells it
continues to to replicate at a low level
um and and really the life cycle is
considered to be quite stealthy it does
not cause high level viremia it does not
cause cell death or inflammation which
are Hallmarks of other kinds of sexually
transmitted infections it has a low
level of replication it uh creates more
of itself by by replicating and
assembling new virus particles which are
then released and cause transmission but
overall there is no profound
immunological response and as a result
HPV can linger within
um within the host and establish latency
so the first step is infection then is
this transient state where it can re it
replicates freely it is often recognized
by the immune system and cleared at this
stage and most HPV infections are
cleared within 6 to 18 months but the
ones that are not cleared by the immune
system go on to establish latency and
then persistence but the key trigger to
cervical cancer development is
integration into the host genome so the
next slide will review that
um and and why this is important to
understand the difference between
transient infection and persistent
infection and the the key factors of
progression is because this really
underpins how the cervical cancer
screening program is rolled out and
understanding the natural history of HPV
informs when a woman is screened and
what kind of triage and management
programs are in place
so as I mentioned HPV infection is quite
common and acquired by young women when
they're sexually active some of these
infections most of these infections in
fact clear within 6 to 18 months and uh
and and are considered transient
infections detecting HPV at this stage
of transient infection leads to a lot of
over calling of HPV infection which does
not progress to any pre-cancerous stage
so that's an important uh fact to
remember
uh what's critically important is to
detect women who are at the highest risk
of progressing into pre-cancer and to
further steps and really getting The
Sweet Spot between transient infection
and persistent infection is the Hallmark
of a good hpv-based cervical cancer
screening program
so in order to determine what makes a
good screening program we have to first
look at the HPV test itself which is
used as the primary screening modality
um and of course the test needs to have
high sensitivity and specificity but
this the sensitivity and specificity is
not just analytical but has to be
clinical in its design and what this
means is the the sensitivity to detect
both active and latent HPV infections
that have the highest risk of
progressing to cervical cancer or
pre-cancerous lesions
um as you know on the market they're
dna-based tests and mRNA are messenger
RNA based tests messenger rna-based HPV
tests predominantly focus on active HPV
infections where there's active
transcription of the viral genome and
they're less sensitive for detection of
latent HPV infections as a result some
of these mrna-based assays can miss
abnormal colposcopy findings and miss
those infections
um that that go on to to proceed into
integration and triggering of
pre-cancerous states and as a result if
any of these women go on to to develop
these pre-cancerous states they they may
require colposcopic management and these
could be missed so the the graphics
below summarize the the studies where
um HPV positive cases were missed when
they were
examined with an mRNA test versus a
dna-based test
um as a result of many studies looking
at the natural history of HPV and also
comparing them to clinical findings both
in terms of cytology and histology and
perspective studies looking at
progression towards cancer we have a far
deeper understanding of the natural
history of HPV and this informed the
evolution of HPV assay design and the
targets that were selected for HPV
assays
um the newer generation of assays focus
on oncogenes E6 and E7 instead of the L1
region the L1 region is part of the HPV
Genome of the surface of the HPV genome
um and
very interestingly this portion of the
HPV genome is used to integrate into the
host
and the integration requires
linearization of the HPV genome and when
the virus integrates into the host
genome through the L1 region it can lead
to some deletions in this region and as
a result HPV tests that focus on the L1
region as their assay Target can
incorrectly provide false negative
results
so that's an important determinant the
other important determinant is what are
the genes that are present in high
abundance during active replication and
later on in persistence when the virus
is integrated into the host genome and
triggering transformation of the of the
cells
and E6 and E7 are the Hallmark genes
that are involved in integration as well
as stable maintenance of that virus
inside the host genome and as you can
see in the figure below an abundance of
L1 positive samples is seen during the
low malignancy transient infection stage
when virus particles are are being
created and released
um but fewer L1 positive cells are seen
in fact you see several cases of L1
negative cases where women have
progressed further in the cancer pathway
where the virus has established itself
it's integrated into the genome
um and you may see cases of sin 2 and
sin 3 where the the sample the cervical
sample is hpvl1 negative so it's quite
perplexing but this is explained due to
the loss of L1 during integration of the
HPV genome into the host
genome
um in contrast high levels of E6 and E7
are present during later stages of the
viruses life cycle in the host and these
are the stages that correlate with
abnormalities
um that are reflected in either sin 2
syn3 or high grade swayamus
inter-epithelial lesions
so as I mentioned the the field of HPV
testing has evolved considerably both in
how the assay is designed in the
platforms that operate the assay one of
the earlier assays was the hybrid
capture two this was a HPV DNA test that
targeted all genes of the HPV virus it
was approved in the U.S for ask us
reflex and co-testing some of the
drawbacks of this test was it did not
have a cellularity control to examine
how well the cervical sample was
collected for testing and it was a quite
a manual test with low throughput so not
amenable for high volume population base
screening
um more tests came onto the market the
Optima e6e7 HPV mRNA test
um was on a high throughput automated
platform approved in the U.S for ascus
reflex and co-testing but didn't yet
have a cellularity control to look at
specimen adequacy
and later generations this is the kobas
L1 HPV DNA test so the difference here
is it's targeting the L1 Gene and as I
mentioned in the previous slide there's
there's some drawbacks and limitations
with L1 detection this test was the
first to be approved in the U.S by the
FDA for HPV primary screening and it
offered the the added feature of
genotyping HPV type 16 and 18.
later generations of the test and now
fast forwarding on to 2018 the BD on
Clarity test targeting the E6 and E7
oncogenes of HPV DNA is approved for use
in surepath and thin prep this is in in
Canada and in Europe
um and it's approved for primary
screening as well as askus reflex and
co-testing so much broader portfolio of
approval it can be performed with
automation it has the cellularity
control so it is building on the the
previous Foundation but the new features
are extended genotyping for uh detection
of other oncogenic high-risk types such
as hpv31 52 and 51 and detection of
other high-risk groups in strategic
panels so I'll describe why this is
important in the in the following slides
but as you can see HPV testing has has
changed from the early progenitor test
which only looked at HPV and provided
did not provide any granular information
on the type of HPV and uh did not have
the automation to really implement this
as a population level program
the importance of this built-in control
is is twofold one that it minimizes
false negative results in the absence of
detection of this endogenous or specimen
adequacy control a negative result may
be due to poor sample collection
and this also is a useful feature as we
consider sub testing of self-collected
specimens which may be another way to
improve diagnostic access and Achieve
our goal of cervical cancer illumination
okay
um and the evolution of HPV testing and
our knowledge of hpv's Natural History
lent itself to further refinement of HPV
screening programs as I mentioned the
original programs began with Pap smears
they moved to path cytology with
liquid-based cytology medium collection
um and as a result of all of the studies
on HPV the prospective evaluations the
clinical trials that examined the
utility of HPV to detect pre-cancerous
lesions and offer early detection
there's been a change in the
recommendations for how cervical cancer
screening is performed the U.S
preventative Services Task Force has
updated their guidelines and they've
periodically updated them and I've put
here in a
um as reference in 2005 the
recommendation was still to screen women
aged 21 to 65 every three years with a
Pap test but by 2018 with all of the
studies and knowledge on HPV these
guidelines were updated to screen uh to
offer three different screening options
one is to continue screening woman age
21 to 29 every three years with a Pap
test but then for women who are older
age 30 to 65 the recommendation changed
to screen every five years with HPV
testing
and they maintained their recommendation
to do HPV and Pap as a co-test every
five years but the recommendations
continue to evolve with a clear
um lean towards HPV primary as being the
superior way to to screen it offers
early detection and a cost-effective way
to to screen for women who are at the
highest risk of progression
and the key difference in in the
recommendations is as a result of the
technological advances we are able to
now have a more objective precise and
automated uh screening modality moving
away from the previous subjective
imprecise manual way of pap smears and
as we continue to evolve our screening
programs I'd like to keep in keep these
three parameters in mind that we remain
objective and improve the Precision with
which we identify
early pre-cancerous
a woman at early stages of development
of pre-cancerous lesions and we perform
the testing and Implement programs that
enable Automation and and high
throughput to really reap the the
benefits of doing this for a large
population
and as I mentioned the revised screening
algorithms from the U.S preventative
task force and elsewhere globally have
reflected on the clinical effectiveness
of HPV the high sensitivity for
detection of syn3 plus
compared to primary cytology or or even
co-testing and also the higher
specificity afforded by by HPV and to go
together with the clinical Effectiveness
is the cost effectiveness of primary HPV
testing
primary HPV has the ability to detect
more cases of syn3 plus so these are the
the really critical cases that have the
highest probability of progressing
towards cancer and more importantly HPV
testing as a program was less expensive
than primary cytology-based cervical
cancer screening
um and while co-testing can detect more
cases of syn3 than HPV testing from a
cost perspective that co-testing
requires screening of a lot of
additional cases as per this study a
hundred thousand additional cytology
tests would have to be performed in uh
566 more colposcopies at an added cost a
significant added cost of 2.38 million
to the cervical screening program in
order to have just an additional
detection of 14 more cases so clearly 14
more cases is significant and these are
complex decisions that involve looking
at the population of interest in every
demographic is is slightly different so
cervical cancer screening programs have
the added challenge of looking at the
local epidemiology of high-risk HPV
genotypes the local local rates of
vaccination and putting that together
with recommendations for a screening
program
this slide summarizes how advances in
HPV
testing our knowledge of hpv's Natural
History the introduction of vaccines and
the changes in cervical cancer screening
programs have dramatically reduced both
the incidence and mortality of cervical
cancer disease and yet you see that it
hasn't gone to zero as much as we've
made great strides in our knowledge and
implementation of new testing and
screening and treatment we have not met
the the goal of eliminating cervical
cancer
um there's certainly been many successes
but they've also been been challenges in
in cervical cancer screening globally
the figure on the left shows the age
standardized mortality rate in different
countries and as you can see there's
been dramatic reductions throughout the
developed World
um where there's been at least a
five-fold decrease in the mortality rate
from the 70s to the 90s but looking
globally there's there's another picture
that emerges there's many countries in
the developing in underdeveloped Nations
where access to basic screening is still
compromising the ability to detect early
cases and certainly
um
preventing early detection and early
treatment leads to Greater incidence and
mortality with cervical cancer
and as you can see some some countries
bear a disproportionate burden of
disease compared to others and this led
to the who
to identify the the goal to eliminate
cervical cancer by 2030 and the reason
that they've come up with this goal is
that they recognize that HPV is a
completely
preventable
infection if vaccination is implemented
but moreover early detection and
appropriate screening programs can catch
any infections that have
um that have that have happened that
have been missed by vaccination and
early screening can prevent progression
into cancer and early treatment as a
result of early screening can once again
limit the woman who who Bears the burden
of disease and or and reduce the
mortality associated with that disease
so this is the the cancer elimination
strategy articulated by the who this was
adopted in 2020 and the key pillars of
this elimination goal is to have 90
percent of girls fully vaccinated with
the HPV vaccine by the age of 15.
um 70 of women
should be screened with the high
performing HPV test by the age of 35 and
then again by the age of 45 and then 90
of women with pre-cancer treated and 90
of women with invasive cancer managed
and while this seems to be a simple uh
uh goal to achieve given the
complexities of HPV
um access to HPV screening vaccination
and treatment
this target is harder to achieve in some
Nations than other
um the other key thing to remember is
HPV vaccination alone is not enough as I
mentioned the older Gardasil vaccine
targeted only HPV 16 and 18 oncogenic
genotypes the new Gardasil non-valent
vaccine added seven more types to that
to that mix but it does not Target all
of the high risk HPV types that are in
circulation so we cannot be lulled into
complacency and this is a reminder to to
remain to remain Vigilant that not all
high-risk HPV types are covered by the
vaccines and the ones that are not
covered are rising in in prevalence
so I'm going to zoom past this this is
the the evolution of the HPV vaccines
um we've gone from the forward valence
to the nine valence and while the nine
Valient is now exclusively used in
developing developed Nations like the US
and Canada
um the woman who previously received the
four valence vaccine who were girls at
the time of introduction back in 2007 in
in Canada they're not all protected from
the other high-risk HPV genotypes that
have now entered the screening
population
so I'm going to move now and focus on
the Canadian cervical cancer screening
landscape
a lot of the data here is drawn
primarily from Canadian sources but I'll
reflect on the us as well so HPV vaccine
access in Canada this is a snapshot of
2022. as you can see all of the
provinces now have some form of an HPV
vaccination program
Ontario was the first to begin back in
2007 with the school-based HPV program
targeting girls who were 12 to 13 years
of age while the program was initiated
back in 2007 adoption has been spotty
with about 50 to 60 percent uptake
across the provinces some have it higher
than that
almost reaching 90 percent in terms of
vaccination uptake but the uneven uptake
once again speaks to the need for early
screening and HPV testing as a way to to
detect cases is
so the current state of cervical cancer
screening across Canada is quite
important and it's uh it's quite
different depending on where you are in
Canada and these these little dots are
my little legend for the different types
of screening that are in place
so the the only province that currently
has gone live with their primary HPV
program is the little province of Prince
Edward Island and you see it here with
the Green Dot
um other provinces are planning HPV
implementation so the province of
Ontario is actively reviewing
applications and is in the process of
implementing this program uh by 2024
early 2025. other provinces are doing
past cytology with a reflex to HPV
anytime there's an abnormal pap cytology
other provinces are
now converted to liquid-based cytology
so Saskatchewan who was on conventional
pap smear is now on liquid-based
cytology
but then there's far too many provinces
that are still on conventional pap smear
which have the the issues of low
sensitivity and specificity and these
include British Columbia and the Yukon
Northwest Territories Nunavut and and
even
Quebec and in the maritimes Nova Scotia
New Brunswick so indeed the majority of
Canadian provinces are still on
conventional pap smear and while there's
an abundance of data and evidence from
other countries such as Australia
Netherlands and Ireland where they've
implemented HPV testing they haven't yet
made the leap over
um to just anything beyond the
conventional pap smear
as a result this is the picture of
cervical cancer incidents in Canada so
this is looking at 2020 and onwards into
the future this is a modeling that was
done by oncosim and here it's showing in
the green line the status quo of
cervical cancer incidents per hundred
thousand and as you can see here in 2000
it's about seven per 100 000 women and
if we continue on the track that we're
in with our spotty vaccination coverage
and uneven implementation of HPV or even
Advanced cytology
um we will continue to see cases of
cervical cancer and deaths
um if we if Canada adopts the who
elimination goals of 90 HPV vaccination
90 HPV testing and follow-up then by
2050 uh Canada would be able to
eliminate
6810 cases and avoid 1750 deaths so this
is quite a significant statistic and
speaks to the need for advancing forward
with not only vaccination but better HPV
testing
um and and follow-up
okay so in addition to uh lagging rates
of vaccination and HPV test
implementation kovid had a profound
impact on cervical cancer screening as
the world uh was completely in the grips
of covid women missed cervical cancer
screening appointments
um here the statistic from the U.S
um by 2019 23 percent of women were
overdue for their cervical cancer
screening and in in Canada the same
picture holds through uh covet
profoundly impacted the the delay in
getting screened and also created
backlogs in testing as laboratory staff
were primarily occupied in in testing
for covid there was staff shortages and
a backlog in cytology
testing and Reporting
so the the amplification of um the
challenges of cervical cancer due to
covid
um you know it's quite profound and we
will likely uh be bearing the burden of
of this uh this delay for many years to
come
um due to increases in the incidence of
pre-cancerous lesions that might have
gone unchecked uh because of my
screening appointments Miss colposcopy
follow-up and this can lead to further
uh exacerbation of Health disparities
for women who miss those appointments
and miss their treatment they're at a
higher likelihood of progressing to
cancer and there's a lot of references
here but together these these lines of
evidence show that cervical cancer
incidence is now threefold higher in
vulnerable populations who have limited
access to screening compared to the
general population and covet Amplified
the disparity in in Access
um pre-pandemic vaccination rates were
around 60 percent
um and those rates dropped dramatically
in 2020 2021 um to less than one percent
in Ontario which is the largest province
in Canada
um so once again that's uh that's
another way that the the preventative
measures against cervical cancer were uh
impacted by covid
uh and what this speaks to is a very
fragmented system
um the there's certainly a lack of
awareness for the need for screening
there were challenges in access to
screening there were challenges in
vaccination coverage as a result the
late diagnosis and a fragmented treating
pathway with lack of follow-up
um is is leading to uh a rise in
incidents and a rise in immortality and
this is something that we will continue
to track uh to see the full impact that
kovid has had on our system backlogs
um the first thing I want to address is
the the systematic inequity and
disparity in diagnostic access in this
fragmented system
um and as a result of this uh inequity
what has been identified is there's many
women in vulnerable populations rural
remote areas who don't have access to
Physicians who don't have access to
proper collection of a cervical specimen
and there's been many studies that have
identified self-sampling where a woman
self-collects a vaginal specimen as a
way to
overcome this barrier for Diagnostic
access and physician access and these
are some articles that have been
published there was also a Cadet
self-sampling Health technology
assessment and this is the last one
where they've examined clinician
acceptability to use self-collected
swabs as a primary cervical cancer
screening method and papers have also
looked at the impact of the covet
pandemic on cervical cancer screening
and once again identified the utility of
self-sampling devices especially
beneficial for for people who face
barriers to access traditional screening
and primary care physicians
challenges can include anything from
distance being in a remote location lack
of Transportation lack of time paid time
off issues of child care cultural
barriers history of trauma we recognize
that cervical cancer cases are currently
higher in certain populations especially
those living in rural remote areas with
low income in First Nations
um and self-sampling could offer a
culturally safe a way a safe and
accurate way to close the gap in
cervical cancer screening
many Studies have now demonstrated that
self-sampling is generally as accurate
as clinician-collected samples for HPV
testing Studies have also shown
favorable uptake and this is has now
been identified as a solution to
increase participation in cervical
cancer screening and promote early ear
detection
okay
um I'm going to touch a little bit on
examples globally where self collection
has been explored and even implemented
in Australia
um they're currently restricting
self-sampling to individuals who are
under screened or never have been
screened
um and here the the patients the
participants obtain a self-sampling kit
and collect the sample in a clinical
setting rather than in their home
however in Netherlands in Finland
um the
the person receives a mailed in
self-collection kit and these
individuals self-collect at home and
mail their sample in for testing at a
lab and both in Netherlands and Finland
they're currently limiting
self-collection only to individuals who
are not participating in a physician
collected organized screening program so
this is another Avenue for women to to
screen themselves but all of these
countries Australia and Netherlands and
Finland are all considering making
self-sampling available to all eligible
screening participants because they
recognize the benefits of improving
access increasing participation and the
improved convenience that this provides
for women
certainly there's challenges with
self-collection
um and and these uh cover a gamut of uh
of issues from low response rate low
number of completed kits that are
responded that are completed and
returned properly
um the the sample itself is collected
with a swab and does not have adequate
cells so cytology triage cannot be
performed so a different reflex testing
mechanism needs to be developed there's
concerns with privacy and packaging of
mail out kits in terms of a system
program cost this can be quite costly to
implement an entire mailout program
so one mitigation strategy is an opt-in
program where some participants request
kits and different jurisdictions are con
are weighing the pros and cons and the
cost benefits of a mail out program
versus a physician-based program
there's certainly regulatory barriers in
having
a self-collection program first of all
HPV assays need to be validated and
thoroughly examined for accuracy
clinical sensitivity and specificity
with self-collected samples taking into
account specimen stability and
reproducibility with use of these
samples
the next point I'm going to touch on the
other challenge is the one of type
replacement due to other high-risk HPV
genotypes and the value that extended
genotyping brings to this issue and and
here's a quote from Dr Jeffrey Isaacson
who says if it's worth vaccinating
against it's worth screening for and
this quote is based on the the
non-valent vaccine that covers several
other high-risk genotypes but screening
programs don't typically identify those
other genotypes and don't identify
whether there's replacement occurring in
our population with other high-risk
genotypes and then there's other quotes
that that reflect this uh the famous one
from Socrates you don't know what you
don't know and what I say is you can't
find what you're not looking for
um and the clinical value of HPV assays
with extended genotyping is that they
they enable
um the tracking of genotype specific
high-risk HPV persistence
um they can identify new types that may
be emerging as threats
um and they can provide more specific
actionable insights based on the high
risk HPV genotype that is detected and
really looking at the different genotype
enhances clinical management algorithms
they provide additional insight and this
can assist in reducing reducing patient
callbacks unnecessary colposcopies and
really further refining the Precision
with which we are rolling out HPV
cervical cancer screening programs and
managing patients
um and why does monitoring persistence
why is that important
um so genotype specific HPV persistence
is really the most important determinant
of cervical cancer risk in women who
test HPV positive so the ability to know
that it's the same HPV genotype that has
persisted at two different visits is a
profoundly important tool for Physicians
to evaluate a person's risk for
developing cancer and here this graph
shows the Orange Line shows that
persistent infection with the same HPV
genotype confers the highest risk of
developing cervical pre-cancer
and the black line here is when you
don't know which HPV type it is so we we
can't comment on what that is but what's
very important to see is this bottom
blue line that shows that HPV infections
that clear between two sequential
screening tests or if you have a
different HPV genotype between the test
that indicates that the first genotype
has been cleared by the immune system
and the woman has gone on to acquire a
new a new infection and this is a very
important piece of information as this
indicates that these women are at lower
risk of developing cervical pre-cancer
it indicates that their immune system is
still capable of clearing infection
um and so this continues to show what
I've described in the previous slide
screening assays that have partial
genotyping that only focus on HPV 16 and
18 have an incomplete picture of uh what
HPV types are circulating and what are
infecting women
um so a simple test will tell you it's
HPV positive but it doesn't give you the
precise information of what HPV type is
infecting a test with extended genotype
can identify genotype specific
persistence Beyond HPV 16 and 18 but
they can also identify when a type
switch has taken place and when
clearance has taken place so here the
the ideal scenario is there's no HPV of
the second visit and a woman has cleared
infection but the other good news story
is when the original infecting HPV type
is cleared and there's a switch in the
HPV type which indicates that the immune
system has cleared the original
infection action and really this HPV
positivity is due to infection with a
new type the worst case scenario is when
there's Persistence of a specific
genotype and here this has the highest
probability of progressing to cancer and
this once again escalates the
physician's management and the Precision
with which this this patient is followed
up
um what we also need to be aware of is
the emerging threats of new high-risk
oncogenic HPV types and the changing
prevalence of these types as a result of
vaccination and this is the concept of
risk replacement
uh many Studies have shown that hpv31 is
emerging as a new risk for cervical
cancer and is one that should be
regarded as a critical high-risk HPV
type in cervical screening programs so
there's many studies listed here and
they're all showing that the prevalence
of hpv31 is increasing as you can see in
this HPV type prevalence ranking column
and the right I'm going to focus on one
study in particular I like the graphics
here what they show is the the the
preponderance of HPV 31 in cases of
cervical pre-cancer so in this pie chart
you see here women with normal biopsy in
the purple and then women with thin ones
into and sin 3. if we look at the women
who have sin three this is really
alarming
um there's uh really the the dominant
HPV type is hpv16 that's that is driving
sin 3 as expected but then the next
highest type is hpv31 followed by all
other 12 in varying proportions and this
is shown in this table here
nope sorry in this table here we see
hpv61
hpv16 has the highest proportion found
in syn3 within 12.9 percent but then
that's followed very with a fairly
significant proportion with HPV 31.
and this once again reiterates the risk
of sin 3 by HPV type in women with
normal cytology so cytology is is
missing
um the the the
risk for pre-cancerous development but
the HPV test is able to detect it and
here we see that hpv31 is the second
highest in terms of HPV associated with
syn3 and any HPV that has a risk higher
than four percent according to the asccp
any HPV associated with syn3 above a
four percent risk threshold should
immediately be referred to colposcopy so
with that principle if we were to apply
that asccp principle of similar
management for similar risk than women
with HPV 31 should also be escalated for
immediate colposcopy given uh what these
statistics are showing
um these studies uh fairly recent
they're looking at HPV types in women
who are vaccinated versus unvaccinated
and what's alarming here this is a study
done in New York City
um they identified that non-vaccine
types high-risk HPV types where were
higher in in women who were vaccinated
so that was an alarming finding another
one this is in the Costa Rica vaccine
trial and they also identify an
increasing prevalence of non-vaccine
represented types in in women who were
previously vaccinated and the the font
is pretty small here I'm I'm not sure if
you can read it
um UCC is the unvaccinated group and
then the HPV vaccinated group
uh and if you look to the far right of
this table that looks that's in three
cases uh we see here that there's High
um fairly High percentages of women who
have HPV 31 and sin 3 in the vaccinated
group so this once again highlights the
need for continued vigilance even in
women who are vaccinated to to have the
ability to screen for other genotypes
and identify risk from other high-risk
types that can lead to sin 3.
so what this is uh I I hope I've
demonstrated uh with all the different
studies and all the all the continuous
improvements in HPV testing in program
delivery
um in understanding of hpv's Natural
History is that we need to continue to
evolve uh cervical cancer screening
programs and this can be done in a
variety of ways
um certainly the the guidelines that
have been put out by asccp have
continued to evolve in recognition of
new HPV tests newer ways to
um to screen the improved sensitivity
and specificity of HPV testing this is
the old aispe guidelines from 2015. as
you can see these are
[Music]
um
quite uh ungranular for lack of a better
word uh primary HPV screening and if
type 16 and 18 are positive then women
are sent off to colposcopy if it's any
of the other high-risk uh HPV types then
they're sent to cytology and then
there's the follow-up cycle that
continues fast forward now to 2019 and
these guidelines were released very
recently there's some key changes here
and the recommendations now are based on
risk rather than the HPV result itself
which is rather nebulous and vague
looking at risk provides a far more
precise way of following up women and
enacting colposcopy and expedited
treatment when necessary
um and so the the new focus is on risk
stratification and individualized
management
um and these consensus guidelines have
several important differences from the
previous guidelines
um rather than considering screening
results screening test results in
isolation the new guidelines they look
at not only the current results but the
past results they look at the patient
factors they look at the history of all
of the results in the context of that
individual patient to create an
individualized assessment of that
patient's immediate risk for pre-cancer
and then their five-year risk of
progressing to pre-cancer or cancer so
this is a big difference in how it was
done before where it was a blunt tool
looking at just HPV but not looking at
the totality of the individual or the
type of HPV and the new guidelines still
retain the principle of equal management
for equal risk
um and the the key Focus now is to
increase accuracy and reduce complexity
for both providers and patients while
maintaining a high degree of safety for
patients
and what as asccp has done is really
Embrace and adopt rapidly emerging
science for the long-term utility of
this screening program
so both the American Cancer Society and
the American Society of colposcopy and
cervical cancer pathology
have recommended extended genotyping as
a key parameter for an updated screening
program and why this is is because it
identifies individual high-risk
genotypes that have a higher likelihood
of infecting women even in the era of
post-vaccination and it enables specific
identification of these types and a more
precise
personalized individualized approach to
screening and follow-up management
um I'm going to go through this very
quickly so if you have a chance go to
the website for asccp they provide
information on their new web-based tool
as well as an app that allows Physicians
to enter in a patient's current HPV
results and pass HPV results in the
context of individualized patient
history
with recommendations for follow-up and
there's different scenarios listed in
the website with video examples that
walk you through how the app works
um here are some screenshots of of the
app basically it allows you to identify
the woman's age bracket age range Uh
current HPV results previous HPV results
cytology results
um and uh the type of HPV and based on
that different recommendations are
provided for follow-up
so over here the recommendation is for
one year follow-up and in the second
example you see immediate escalation to
colposcopy given the higher immediate
risk of sin 3 for a particular HPV type
um once again
um the the type of HPV test that is used
for screening is critically important uh
both in terms of its design and
performance criteria
um the valgent criteria for validation
of HPV genotyping tests have evolved
themselves initially they focused on
clinical sensitivity and specificity of
the test but the current guidelines have
extended beyond that
focusing on the high negative predictive
value which provides higher confidence
for longer screening intervals with the
with the HPV test early detection of
high risk HPV instead of pre-cancer
cells by cytology is afforded by this
High sensitivity and high negative
predictive value but also how the test
is performed on an automated platform
with reproducibility consistent
performance
and efficiency
the newer elements of the
the test design and performance criteria
are the the assay targets themselves for
the viral genes as well as the the human
endogenous control
um the ability to have extended
genotyping and detect emerging threats
from risk replacement
the ability to promote individualized
risk assessment and clinical management
principles
um and a test that is Progressive and
adaptable to new screening modalities
such as self-collection and the ability
to perform new types of triage testing
whether they be looking at methylation
markers or other host genome biomarkers
for more personalized and precise triage
for management of patients
so together an integrated solution needs
to look at
the ability to do testing in a sensitive
and specific manner the ability to
identify an extended panel of high-risk
genotypes to track persistence and type
replacement and also offer a way to have
new modalities of screening including
self-collection as a means to improve
diagnostic access so really it's not
just the test in isolation it's putting
it all together in an integrated program
that enables
accurate acceptable High screening
coverage overcoming any capacity
limitations of the system whether it be
Physicians whether it be the ability to
reach a physician or a Laboratory
Testing and optimize how a woman is
managed which involves wrist
stratification in to enable more precise
management and to minimize invasive
procedures unnecessary procedures such
as colposcopy and further treatment when
a woman can safely be followed up
without these interventions and really
at the end of the day it's putting all
of this together into a scalable
implementation program so that it has
the wide breadth of a population program
and and beyond that augmenting it with
the digital tools for successful rollout
adoption understanding of the program
with continuous education of why the
program is evolving
um this slide just summarizes everything
I've said
um and essentially a strong system is
necessary to overcome all of the
challenges for cervical cancer screening
um it's not just the test alone but
putting the test together within a
program that has adequate Outreach for
both The Physician and the patient and
provides the added features of extended
genotyping to to be vigilant and examine
risk replacement offers self-collection
as a way to overcome barriers to
diagnostic access
provides the ability to refine risk
stratification and triage so we can
evolve in patient management with more
precise individualized management
programs and
leverages digital tracking tools to to
improve follow-up of patients as well as
a better understanding and informatics
of all of the data we accumulate late
with cervical cancer screening so with
that I'm going to end I think I'm a
little bit overtime but hopefully we
still have a few minutes for for
questions
well thank you Dr reppa pergata for your
informative presentation your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor BD for underwriting today's
educational webcast unfortunately since
we are running short on time all
questions submitted today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you had provided at
the time of registration
but before we go I'd like to remind you
that this webcast can be viewed on
demand and lab Roots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event so until next time
take care everyone goodbye